attention attention New York City New
York the Big Apple baby are you garbage
live is coming to The Gramercy Theater
February 4th baby you're not going to
want to miss it it's going to be our
biggest show yet Army of garbage unite
baby Long Island New Jersey Brooklyn
Queens Connecticut Staten Island fly in
Alaska I don't care tickets go on sale
December 7th you need the early access
code garbage to get them before the
general public use code garbage December
7th get your tickets let's go baby
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage hey yeah it's a
little show we sit there with your
favorite comedians and we find that at
the girl to be classy after just a big
old piece of trash I'm your host Dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at antuti's basement
she's upstairs baking some Christmas
cookies okay listening to the Ozzy
Osbourne Christmas album
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table that seemed like a patronizing
chuckle if you ask me he is the CEO of
Ru garbage he's in a mood he is the
international businessman himself give
it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan Hey gang
thanks for tuning in I appreciate all
the support as always please make sure
you rate review subscribe over there on
iTunes even though it don't mean nothing
no more and then obviously uh full video
available on YouTube version of those
numbers are
you got open face you got turkey you got
legs you got everything you want couple
of wishbones too
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire that magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
and twos crosses the t's dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins it's
our good pal
Toby McMullen everybody hey what's up
dudes hey what's going on buddy when
would you guys pop off the Christmas
carols in the house for us it was day
after Thanksgiving and it was Jesus
Christ Superstar it was Randy Rhodes
hey Jesus Christ Superstar is not a
Christmas sure isn't but it's about JC
and the folks it it is when you're drunk
put on Bat Out of Hell
entries of confusion uh I gotta be
honest with you like I said I got a
record player not too long ago the bird
came that bird went to a flea market
over the weekend in Brooklyn came back
with a couple of with a Christmas album
really who is it she threw that on uh
it's a little Frank Sinatra while Barbra
Streisand I forget a little mix got a
little Babs on there yeah
oh man she was a monster wouldn't mind
taking over I wouldn't mind taking a run
at her now what are you talking about I
love an old broad let's go that's my
kind of thing what do you say Christmas
carols I think
that's singing Christmas music Christmas
music yeah yeah I'm a Nat King Cole man
oh God damn that boy you could be
singing about anything dude he'll get
you emotional yeah
um I got them rocking I got them rocking
now they're they're rocking in the in
the car I got that serious station set
in there [ __ ] Christmas traditions I
don't mind that people get all bought
that people get all bent out of shape
about [ __ ] ah it's not even
Thanksgiving and we're playing Christmas
music yet it's like when they pushed it
up a little bit this
year's a channel get Spotify put on are
you garbage we ain't playing it
buddy I'm down all the way sure I like
it uh-huh soon as [ __ ] Halloween's
over get that candy out of the CVS and
start putting up my apartment start
putting those Christmas trees in there
sure
yeah only problem I just I was on a ride
down here and they're setting up the
[ __ ] Christmas tree stands already
the Canucks are coming down now it's the
same it's the same uh it's the same guys
as last year too like gypsies when they
come down dude they come down I don't
know where they're sleeping they drink
our Hooch sleep with our women oh yeah
they do they clean up spring break for
that this is as far as [ __ ] maple
syrup cologne and [ __ ] Tweed jackets
whatever they're wearing some may say
they even started that two weeks ago did
they they're already selling them oh oh
okay
by the way what high school movie are
you trying out for you can't see T-Bone
but he's got this stocking hat on yeah
it looks like you're on your way to
[ __ ] biology right now yeah I'm the
coolest kid in school dude Toby McMullen
is 12th year senior I gotta get the Mr
O'Reilly's class stat where's my board
dude they held me back for lighting
farts with the Bunsen burner
Toby McMullen is the 32 year old
freshman that's not bad give me 1200
words on it I'll see if I can pitch it
to the suits as I was saying the only uh
tough thing about this year on the East
Coast when we did that Chrissy chaos
podcast shout out to Chrissy day shout
out to Chris Yankees create Chrissy
Chrissy I know the man he does all right
that kid fantastic but we were talking
with him about how great you know how
much we love like the Eastern Seaboard
you know Boston I've ever said that okay
big fan of the Eastern Seaboard best
waterways in all the world they got the
best tributaries you could answer for
none of that brackish water like you
have dance out there who says that the
Eastern Seaboard that's what we live
when you're looking at the Doppler 10
000 the Eastern seaboard East Coast yeah
the East Coast the Seaboard but right
now they are I'm too I'm too lazy to do
it and it really and it really doesn't
stop right there in the God I'm not
gonna believe another word out of your
mouth I'm dry what do you mean I'm out
of weed what do you mean what do I mean
my skin I'm dry I'm dying okay and this
looks sweaty to me so I was a little
confused the moisturizer doesn't work
and the soap that I use it's just it's
the worst man stop going soap you're
washing all you're washing all the oils
off your body go all natural oh you
don't want you don't want that no just
get them do the pit do the you know run
the run the bases I can't do that why
not your arms aren't dirty are your arms
getting dirty I just seeped
disgustingness trust me you wouldn't
want me to stop showering I'm not 12 I
didn't say stop shower and I said adjust
what you're doing in the shower that's
way different
now lay off the hoagies
no meatballs no meatballs in a bed
though
you're just in there it's a big thing of
soup
here you're slurping your way out
there's like full onions floating around
you and stuff ah it is nice soup weather
oh it's a real good soup something Hardy
give me something give me a split pea
nice goulash not bad I like a Chili a
turkey chili swear to God again they're
dropping some [ __ ] bombs on me this I
thought I'm sitting here I thought I
knew you're my best pal in the World
Turns up you like chili talk about
Scoops
yeah I'm all ashy do you do anything you
do any routine you're you're a Scottish
man you do any uh moisturizing at all no
I just and I just realized I'm I'm a
raisin every day of my life yeah it
looks like grip tape from here what are
you talking about
just put sex wax all over
what about you I do the
um shine up that Dome and anything oh my
gosh a little Turtle Wax on it a little
buff and shine
get that zambona they use at the grocery
store you should trick your forehead out
and get the engine that comes out of the
hood like that would you make it a hot
rod
everybody comes over in my garage just
Tinkers on me every couple of guys
hanging out drinking a beer it's like
[ __ ] Home Improvement
um I use uh the Nivea Nivea okay all
right you do use a cream yeah I have a
little bit of that it's more like a it's
not like a cream it's not like a liquid
cream yeah no I know what you're talking
about sometimes you can get the travel
size it comes in only travel with one
every time we go on the road
dingleberry yeah I love it um I feel
like I'm really buffing out my face with
it too it's like a good like uh it's a
good consistency yeah it's good stuff I
have some in the car I used it in my
hair for a little bit this summer when I
was staying off the uh
but I was staying off the crew forming
cream for a little bit my hair was
growing times are tough moisturizer is
good for the hair okay A little tip out
there a little little secret H Foley tip
don't wash your hair kids and put a
little Moisturizer in it if you do wash
it put a little moisturize in it
afterwards don't use those leave-in
conditioners girls don't use the dry
shampoo okay keep it real real simple
got natural oils up there you don't want
to mess I keep the oils although I
haven't washed my hair in 10 years and
look at me so you know do what you wish
you're doing the fight off you did it
you'd be blowing away like a daisy
whatever they're called dandelion [ __ ]
willows hey clean it up we're gonna get
demonetized over the holiday season God
damn it Jesus is Christ Gang This is a
family episode it sure is as you know
when you sign up for the old patreon
over there which as wefore mentioned is
it's a good time over to get a lot of
content a lot of and if you join that
you get like the past [ __ ] 18 months
of content too a lot of bad get
everything archives a lot of bang for
your buck as a 90s dad would say a
little more bang for your buck you know
what I mean you'll need a lot of bang
for your buck we're talking about
hookers right I'm trying to get my dad
to buy a vacation a lot of bang for your
buck yeah they come with a couple of
shotguns some serious business yeah but
as you know when you sign up for the old
patreon you get a question right on the
air uh you got Kippy and me here to read
those questions for you right now here
on are you garbage who wants to be oh
you guys sometimes you fall into [ __ ]
the guy from Slumdog Millionaire voice
I've been doing it and I've been trying
to work my way out of this uh this Tutti
slump what do you mean I got one out of
me today
I didn't trust it though yeah but what
do you mean I wasn't confident in it
don't tell any well I laughed I
appreciate it all right thank you can't
get a read on this guy I feel like I
feel like I'm gonna turn I'm gonna I'm
gonna it's it's slowly coming back go
through a little bit of a drought with
them I don't get you too much but
sometimes the kids at home enjoy them
when you don't I think everybody enjoys
them I also enjoy them listen buddy
you're still in the hunt for the
playoffs all right yeah listen you're
not fully out yet that's what I'm saying
I'm saying right now it's like
mid-season I've took in a couple of
lumps you know what I mean got sent down
to the miners for a little bit hooked up
with a Denny's waitress and I came back
into pros and a busboy and a busboy
I call that the Denny sampler
um now I feel like I'm starting to get
in into the Zone I was in a little bit
of a writer's block for a little while
did some of that Ayahuasca that's really
coming out okay good that stuff he can't
do an act out in totally you're kind of
your hands are tied put it in an
omelette
um yeah all right let's get into it boys
we got a couple of barn burners over
there and a patreon
um this one coming in from an
international homie up there
oh shout out to him this is from Shane
uh never have one red Doreen worked Zoom
meetings my co-worker lights up multiple
burpees on camera every time
unless you're an auto mechanic that
shouldn't be allowed I assume
at least visually a zoom conference call
is like an all you're at work
right you wouldn't sit in your off
that's I don't know
that's a dirtbag move
it's a it's a dirtbag movie okay but
that's not there's smoke it in your crib
unless you're out unless you're outside
but then it's even worse I know that's
what I'm saying so you're smoking
indoors just quit your dude you're doing
daytime cigs inside that's wild
nighttime drunk Sure hold on let's let's
break this down piece by piece Canada's
also cold I get that is it is it frowned
upon Shore Is it against company policy
that's the big question and that could
go for that could go for eating that
could go for
drinking I think you should handle it
like you would in a person-to-person
meeting from a professional standpoint I
mean this guy's ripping darts on a zoom
there you believe that got a good idea I
say promote him what are you kidding me
that's the kind of [ __ ] Maverick you
want running the company kids a goddamn
cowboy no way that kid ain't gonna be
around a long time let me ask you this
can you drink during a zoom meeting like
a bottle of water you mean Hooch no I'm
talking about booze no you're not you're
at work you're not in the office you're
working you're at your home I listen I
understand your argument but you're
working you're still working what about
eating can't smoke crystal meth either
when I quit
uh yeah you're allowed to take my resume
you're allowed to eat in your office
you're sitting there you got a ham
sandwich or whatever sure but it's also
like if you're with a client and you're
like you know your chain smoke you're
you're chain smoking Bernies yeah that's
a tough look I ain't buying nothing from
you I'd love to know what they do for
him it's got to be something blue
collarish I don't think you would be
having [ __ ] Zoom meetings he's a
cardiologist what you're going to want
to do is Babe where's my light ah that
guy's also talking to people off screen
a lot too yeah he's yelling at the dog
get out of him go get it
man what a kooky time that we were in
when all that was when all that was
going down uh-huh all the zoomy when
everybody was getting used to it
you know what I mean you got used to it
like day two you really oh you really
were living your best life during the
quarantine man come on I didn't mind it
though when we were zoo we were doing
this show uh we were zooming I'd go up I
was staying down the shore I'd go up
into the empty bedroom or on the living
room my wife would leave for the hour or
whatever have a nice cup of coffee
bottle of water only had a dress from
the waist up you know what I mean I'm in
my little Underoos and a clean T-shirt
oh he still does that I have no pants on
right now stand up we blur it just a
little it's a little quarter a little
tiny blur
my little peepee you leave him alone
he's a good kid sure
um home run of a question can't believe
that hasn't come up really I guess
because probably not a lot of people are
doing that I would assume no people like
to keep their job that's crazy dude uh I
want to pick take a pic and send it uh
send it on social or something please uh
this is from Bago milk talking turkey
have you ever cooked an entire box of
stove tops Stove Top Stuffing not at
Thanksgiving yeah I don't think I have
but I think we would do stuffing
we would do we're a stovetop shake and
bake household family you would do it I
thought like I'd never who's met dude
you're making stuffing yourself I've
that's something that I would that I
really at like the Titan house the house
we lived in in South Philly really yeah
that that's uh just got that's yeah
that's um I'm an adult but I'm I'm broke
that's when I would do it all right here
this is what I call Mac and Cheese in my
head my mom if she ever did that
what I would have smashed it with a
cookie sheet what are you kidding me
that don't hurt by using the WWE
she starts putting that out when it's
not that not not November I think we
might have right that's sacrilegious I
don't know this is also where my memory
gets real chicken bake all day I
understand that yeah no no my working
mom no stepmom my mom never did chicken
bake stepmom did shake and bake oh okay
um trying to win me over uh
egg chicken Rice-A-Roni house and when
they would make the beef I'd pick around
the carrots I didn't like veggies at the
time man that Rice-A-Roni oh a little
vermicelli in there oh man damn if you
cook Rice-A-Roni to the perfect liquid
like liquidity the perfect moisture it's
a kind of soup kinda not kinda
everything what was the best
what was the best is after dinner when
you were clearing the plates there would
be some in the pot and it would be
cooled down and it became like this like
wood chips kind of oh dude just oh yeah
I used to put it in Solo cups and take
it up to my room
flip
[Laughter]
all right who's up now
let's play tank up
in that uh
uh is getting more and more popular I
think at like
haha a lot let's open it up for Taylor
Swift uh no is the cup putting things in
cups and eating them out of cups I see I
see the Instagram videos where people
have a cake say it's a birthday party
they have a cake everybody takes a cup
or a glass and just Scoops out some of
it I like that that's the Grammy it's
real like foreign
cups of cereal so I could rollerblade
when I was like eight
just like out there in the streets with
Cinnamon Toast Crunch and a [ __ ] with
milk yeah you're eating it with a spoon
uh-huh oh my God yeah I mean my brother
blew my mind it was they wanted to go
play hockey I was like hold on I'm about
to make a boat Syracuse put it in a cup
and take it outside with you I was like
what did you just say nobody called the
news dude you're the smartest guy in the
world
because hey guys I'll have one with you
and we both poured it in and then went
to [ __ ] play hockey or whatever and
there's just you just just floating down
the street oh yeah I gotta had a clip my
dad always bought instead of a couple of
diabetes
breakfast dude I don't know you're
talking about that would be anything to
see you hit a rock
you imagine him
probably a deuce deuce and a quarter
[ __ ] rolling down the street
smoking endos sipping on gin and juice
milk mustache I'm playing forward
Kyle when I picture you as a kid you
always have a chocolate milk mustache
now only on Sundays when we went to the
diner
oh that's funny
um yeah man a big putting stuff in a cup
love it that uh
uh like goldfish so you can like take in
the car or whatever fill up a cup of
goldfish or whatever it's perfect for it
come on I'm talking about like Matt we
that was at a wedding can I get a
rundown of [ __ ] your Goldfish flavors
top to bottom I like the traditional
cheddar okay
um I like a pretzy mm-hmm
um that's kind of where it starts and
ends with me that's really all we had
when I was banging we didn't have the 19
different tri-colored flavors well it's
only real I mean you got your pizzas in
there too Pizza became popular oh okay
yeah the pizzas I'll take the pizzas man
but not all the time but you catch a
pizza like once every two three months
oh that whole bag is sure dude but as
I've testified before uh you know
congress senate many places I'm a
Cheez-It man I prefer the cheese it hey
I don't uh you know I'm right there my
cousins were big into the we don't keep
Cheez-Its at the house though ever never
Cheez-Its at the house no goldfish
yeah we didn't keep either one of those
at the house I had to go to my cousins
to get my Cheez-It fixed they had all
the snacks to the plug was that's who
the plug was yeah they had it you'd
knock on the window and uh walk around
to the back
um they had the huge it looks like a
huge chocolate milk container carton
okay
oh yeah Cheez-Its yeah no I'm sorry of a
goldfish we kept those at the crib that
would end up in the room too yeah
instead of making the trip downstairs
Patty was big on the pretzel rods who
was it yeah they were okay do you
remember Penny sticks
what am I we're friends right I thought
the penny stick yeah talking about the
little Banger box
they were coming bags bags yeah nah
these came in a little square yellow box
no that's not Penny and they'd have the
plastic over there that's not Penny but
they were a little thin yeah those those
were not that great between that and a
pack of those the snack pack with the
cheese and the crackers
yeah kick that [ __ ] down the road uh no
Penny sticks were like a real they sell
them at the at the place of my
neighborhood uh they're like a more
artisanal pretzel Rock are they Twisted
no which I never really cared for
because they were always like
multi-grainer so I had honey on them
kick rocks yeah give me the high Patty
was big on them the honey twists uh they
were all right in a pinch you know I'd
rather eat salt dust though in a pinch
if you're starving and the game's on and
you have a couple of screamers you got a
screaming cold soda oh you can make and
you can make just plain Saltines work
wait what did I call it what was the
thing that was just talking not honey
sticks Penny sticks looks like the
driest snack ever made oh no they're
buttery
they're [ __ ] great my aunt my Aunt
Mary Catherine shout out to her used to
I Googled him penny stocks comes up
these things no regulation fantastic let
me say
so I'll pick this up for them oh okay
yeah they were all right I still sell
them in my neighborhood that's like a
Pennsylvania Dutch kind of vibe yeah it
might be a penny Pennsylvania Global
operation I don't know Kim how about
that raycon oh Reika let's talk business
here gang doesn't matter whether you're
naughty nicer somewhere in between
raycon's got you covered yep use
yourself a pair of Premium audio
products over there at raycon whether
it's listening to music taking work
calls or blasting a holiday playlist I
like watching porn with mine raycon's
got you covered talk about surround
sound that makes you feel like you're in
bed with them
talk about naughty baby game they got
wireless earbuds headphones speakers
and they offer premium sound comfortable
fit up to 54 hours of battery life at a
price half of what the other guys charge
you they were nice enough to send us a
couple of pair I use them all the time I
rocked them they're fantastic
uh plus they make it easy to shop for
every Tom Dick and Antoni in your life
with holiday gift guides you're always
going to get the best deal when you use
our special link buy raycon.com garbage
uh the raycon website even offers buy
now pay later options because
everybody's in a pinch uh and for the
next month raycon will have a countdown
to Christmas with new pop-up flash deal
for you to take advantage of every
single day right now go to buy recon.com
garbage you get 15 off site live with
code holiday plus free shipping that's
code holiday at biracon.com garbage for
15 off your raycon purchase buy
raycon.com garbage do it gang the show
is sponsored by betterhelp so listen up
Screwballs all right the holiday
season's here everyone's being being
driven crazy life doesn't come with an
owner's manual we're all figuring things
out you know I'm figuring things out
you're not but you're you say you are if
you need help better help can help
they've connected with three million
people with their licensed therapist and
help them all out sure they sure have uh
I've been using it for a couple two
three four five six months now whatever
it's been it's been fantastic it's easy
peas they got the messaging you can do
the you can do the face to face the
calls whatever you want uh you can just
text if you want right yeah it's a
message like in the app or on the site
so if you're like I'm going on a
computer I go hey hey guy I'm about to
jump off the bridge he goes hey don't do
that out of nowhere you can just hit
them up yeah he might not he's not like
necessarily sitting around sure you got
a lot of patience these things happening
but uh yeah it's a it's a it's a it's a
spin on on normal therapy you know what
I mean uh it has the world's largest
therapy service better help us match
three million people with professional
license invented therapist available 100
online plus affordable just fill out a
brief questionnaire to match with a
therapist if things aren't clicking you
can easily switch to to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be easier no waiting
rooms no traffic no endless searching
for the right therapists learn more and
save ten percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com garbage that's betterhelp
help help.com garbage my aunt used to
get these like they were like butter
pretzels
you know what'll be talk about games oh
yeah but then they got you you feel that
all over your hands and stuff you're
like cover it's like an oil slick who
cares
um as long as I can handle the remote
I'm good uh you know you know what I'll
still go home it'll be at the crib the
[ __ ] Snyder's blazing buffalo
pretzels or the honey mustards
my stepdad still bangs with those many
times I have told you the impact that
the
Schneider's pretzel pieces honey mustard
I think it's honey and onion it's not
honey mustard it's something whatever it
is no it's honey mustard I think when
those are [ __ ] to get you in the
jowls and I don't oh yeah when those
things hit the market they were a
coveted possession in our house the
[ __ ] flavor on them is so pungent
there's I don't know it's like they
change it at a molecular level sometimes
you just find little little little
chunks of the flavors yeah they're not
even pretzel you're just eating mustard
it's like finding Dark Matter it is it's
whatever it is it's like [ __ ]
compounded on itself dude so good it's
honey mustard and onion honey mustard
you were both right they tripped up on
you
um damn uh all right let's keep it
rolling here uh this one's from Sean
never had one red ever date someone with
milk crate furniture
that's a tough look dude you're dating
you're dating a guy or a gal with milk
crate Furniture I think it was
acceptable
uh for a certain time
to have your record collection or your
CD records of course because it's
perfect for that I think in a I think it
can be kind of kitschy in like a storage
way if you got one or two for like kids
toys or [ __ ] whatever I can see that
sure but if like your coffee table is
built on [ __ ] commingled bins yeah
rocks a couple of rosenbergers remember
them that's a local Philly thing
rosenbergers of course shout out to it
um that any palette is kind of tough
unless it's done right the problem is
those things aren't usually done right
if it's done right it looks professional
looks cool whatever I'm with that
but a lot of times it gets real clunky
and you forget to finish the one side
the two things don't match you know did
you ever have a broken couch
yeah we just had you just broke a couch
in here like two weeks ago okay I don't
think that was necessary Toby cut that
please
um
back in the day coming up
did you ever break a leg on a couch I
don't think so I'd have to put like uh
the phone oh something yeah like
coasters or something under it coasters
I think we did something along those we
had like a stack of coasters
most Immaculate coffee table in the land
man margaritaville's got these powerful
coasters they'll hold two three hundred
pounds
that's a big quote were you a coaster
family I mean I was yelled at sure to be
a coaster guy so your mom had coasters
readily available yeah wow that's pretty
classy uh coasters are real classy yeah
but sometimes they were like they they
were stolen from like Sullivan's Bar and
Grill or whatever you know what I mean
they weren't like now she's got like a
nice not marble but like slate or
something like that with a little soft
part underneath like the cork or
whatever but like what we've said those
things have begotten ver those things
all that kind of consumer products have
become very affordable
I feel like those back and those are
probably like 12 bucks now we're back in
the day they were like 49.99 sure that's
spending 39.99 on [ __ ] Court yeah I'm
[ __ ] coasters she my penny tried for
a little while but we broke her we
ruined everything eventually yeah but we
we had to catch him into my apartment
um when I lived on 2nd Avenue back in
the day
um the one side went the one peg went
that got a couple phone books put
underneath it the back one went that got
like a couple of textbooks or whatever
was back there that eventually once two
of them break you just get rid of those
things all together and the camera was
on the ground I got a low rider
throw some hydraulics on this thing
really stun which for a little while is
like getting a new couch uh-huh you know
what I mean yeah that's why I was never
allowed obviously to have my bed on the
floor but I did think that was pretty
cool like in high school if like kids
sure it's a little like uh
yeah like uh not devious is the but like
a little edgy you know something cool
it's cool because you're like you're not
on you're like you're it's like what
like cool guys in there when they're 23
do that yeah and as a teenager you want
to be a cool 23 year old yeah I got to
do that at a certain point wherever I
was living I liked it for a little while
it's a little different perspective
change my boys in college uh Pat Phil X
you know the the whole the whole crew in
their house they had a big couch right
and I think the the legs got busted off
of that so it was like a low rider and
then they found another couch like on
the street and brought that into the
living room as well but build it like
put it on like recycling bins or
something so it was statey they had
stadium seating couches so you would
have like four Dudes on the couch up top
and then four Dudes down the I mean
Sunday football was wild at that point
that's that's like something Barstool
does yeah it was real [ __ ] cool I
walked in I'm like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] Stadium couches
guys walking around selling beers let me
get two I'll pay you back tomorrow who
wants a cold one yeah by the way that
reminds me those those guys selling the
beers at the World Series they knew we
were looking to to drink a couple of
Pops three guys just posted up they
would open up I'd be like halfway done
he's like playing like lift the back up
for me so I chug it quicker I got two
more for you
ah shout out to the fighting fills
uh all right let's see this one's from
one ten dollar homie
it is it garbage to put dirty dishes in
a loaded clean dishwasher just to avoid
unloading the dishwasher at that moment
yes it is but I respect the move
that this is like a big thing for me I
it like depresses me it feels like I
can't I know for some reason that
triggers me as being like a big piece of
[ __ ] yeah of not even having like the 12
the 10 seconds the 8 Seconds of energy
to be like I'm gonna put these three
cups these two forks in this one plate
away how long do you think it takes to
empty a dishwasher I was thinking about
that this morning how long you because
when my mom would ask me to do that when
I was a kid
I would rather take the death penalt oh
my god dude find it like the lids or the
whatever same thing with the trash and
it's just and but then you look back on
it like I do that for her now
it takes a minute 90 seconds two minutes
tops I go home we leave on Sunday I drag
the track you know drag the cans out to
the to the street put the cans out
um you know unload the dishwasher sweep
up this we cleaned out the garage when I
was home on Sunday
and when I was a kid it was like this is
gonna take me seven years oh dude it
takes about 10 minutes and you feel
great after you do it like I have that
so bad I have such an inherent laziness
no
I'm telling you I do but then he really
thought I didn't believe you I've been
dragging you all over the country for
[ __ ] 18 months I'm aware but then
when you do it it's crazy how much
you're like God damn that was nothing
and you feel great about sure you're
accomplishing little things crazy little
things have you ever had someone come
over to your apartment and hid dirty
dishes in the oven oh yeah I'll still
put it dirty wait why would they hide
dirty dishes in your oven no you hide
your dirty dishes in your oven I thought
it was some kind of weird sex thing I
don't know what he's up to over there
now things are getting geeky uh I'll do
it now in the in the the wife gets real
upset about it you put them in the oven
uh it depends it depends what it is
again I've testified to this many times
straight into the fridge that's crazy to
me straight to the fridge
they might go in the fridge
the guest it's not even a guest thing oh
wait
don't touch that pizza crust stay out of
order from under my bed will ya do I
keep my dildos and my baking sheets
oh man if you're hiding them under your
bed no better off
garbage I only started doing it uh where
if I make something and it's a me thing
like if I make something in a pan right
reheat something whatever and then I
don't clean it and I'm like [ __ ] I'm
leaving the house
it's a mouse thing sure it's a mouse yes
I go [ __ ] I'm just more important I'm
gonna throw this pan in the oven because
you store pan I store pans in the oven
as it is so like if there's like a
frying like a frying pan that has like
some residual whatever cheese or butter
or oil on it just throw it in there
until I can come back and clean it you
want to piss off Patty Foley real bad
make a couple ilios pizzas in the oven
leave like crust of it and stuff like
that in the oven in the cookie sheet
then she rolls in to make dinner fires
up the oven to preheat it and it starts
smoking what the [ __ ] is this penis
Patty I love you but that's your fault
you gotta get eyes on the oven before
you turn it on
that
you gotta [ __ ] check man you can't
just blindly turn on an oven that's
crazy
no way can I have my sneakers in there
yeah no that's not but I now that we
have a dishwasher that is like uh to me
it is a a point of
to me the kitchen and the dishes are a
point of where I'm at mentally but
here's the thing if you watch that twice
if you wash them twice they're even more
clean no it's not I feel like they're
worth there's a different residue on
them because they're too clean you know
what I mean they they hold the soap a
little different you know if it ran
through twice what are you using by the
way because I'm about to be a dishwasher
man oh I've been out of the game for a
long time I haven't had additions
you get done there's a naked bro naked
redhead in there remember that redhead
in the Irish Spring commercials no the
redhead and the in the they were all
assassins man God well the Herbal
Essence would show they were topless but
they would show here up right like they
would show the oh my God it's always a
nice shower yeah it'd be weird if they
were in a [ __ ] truck stop
these are hot broads they got money
washing their hair and high fruit those
corn syrup yeah
um what are you using over there uh uh
we are uh as of recent and I'm pushing
back on some of this stuff uh my wife is
like a very uh
anti-chemical broad you want the hard
stuff I want give me the [ __ ] you
know give me the Cascade [ __ ] that
[ __ ] all that'll take the paint off your
car that's that that's embedded in our
brains I want that Cascade works I need
the chemicals I need the poison the
carcinogens that's what cleans a plate
nothing like that smell when you open up
the dishwasher after uh after it's done
that hot that hot steam hits you with
that lemony lime smell or whatever it is
uh but now we use like uh [ __ ] you
know she's all kind of like organic or
like less you know
the Seventh Generation type thing just
like the little yeah the little jaw and
the little the little thing I got that I
get the multi-purpose spray of that yeah
that I gotta use the roaches see that
and they're like [ __ ] you yeah [ __ ]
yeah they don't even have Windex they
grab it and throw it back at you like a
protest
um yeah now we're big on all that and
I'm there's certain things where I'm
like
I'm using Kaboom you know what I mean
you know you can have all the baking
soda toothpaste you want yeah but like
I'm coming heavy bike on a couple two
three things
I'm gonna strap the [ __ ] A-bomb on
something bro when I clean the toilet
it's Scrubbing Bubbles or nothing I'll
fight with her in my head he's just
chemical warfare here because I'll be
cleaning she comes in like you know we
have the [ __ ] you know we got that
hippie [ __ ] yeah no [ __ ] listen give me
the Cami so I'm cleaning it I'm using
chemicals no [ __ ] that's what we're
doing I'm not scrubbing the shots Dad
used chemicals his dad used chemicals
his dad was an alcoholic and that's what
we do take that Patchouli [ __ ] back to
the [ __ ] Grateful Dead parking lot
I'm gonna [ __ ] use it listen we'll
call you on Christmas when we need the
frankincense all right until then it's
Kaboom or nothing but I haven't had a
dishwasher now that I'm sitting here
thinking about it ever in my adult life
at Titan Street we had one you didn't do
any dishes you didn't cook there no yeah
the last time you lived in a residence
with a dishwasher would have washed my
bong in there so it was 11 years ago or
something 12 12 years ago I lived in a
place that had a dishwasher before that
that's [ __ ] Patty's never had a
dishwasher yeah Game Changer it's a
proper Game Changer but they're small
I'm gonna sit there and look at it all
right it's one way it's running they're
real like Tom Hanks and Cast Away when
you just turning the light on that's the
only problem like I did uh yesterday I I
loaded it yesterday it was all the [ __ ]
I couldn't fit all of our dishes in
there there's like a two tree stragglers
out you know what I mean
yeah played a cup whatever because the
tiny little itty bitty ones but hmm it
is what it is yeah that's trash dude I
don't even know how he got there milk
crates no putting dirty dishes in the
dishwasher when it works in there that
was one shout out to one
[Music]
um all right let's see this one's from
Nick have you ever painted over an
outlet and switch plate intentionally
Outlet what's the switch plate like the
that like they did that one oh New York
New York landlords they'll paint over
you if you're standing in there sure
they will yeah 100 yes and I've done
that I'm always real shitty but I'll
give you a good 75 of the room will be
done well and then after that
I get real shaky I don't move the tape I
[ __ ] will wing it here who needs to
tarp down and I [ __ ] it up I only worked
with one guy where I had to be on point
with that it was a general contractor I
worked as a side job when I was at the
theater was all these old houses in Rose
Valley Pennsylvania real high-end [ __ ]
like a real real real ritzy people stuff
and you had to do it right like you had
like the old wooden doors you know they
had like the you know they'd be like
different wood in the the four little
four little pockets you had to do those
a certain way how to do these a certain
way yeah that's like professional
painting yeah yeah 100 yeah but if it's
my place dude just throwing the bucket
on the wall I don't give a [ __ ] okay
let's talk about box awesome oh baby
bespoke pose love that box awesome love
that box awesome you know what the best
part about it is what's that the
surprise the unexpected you get
something cool you open it up it's like
Christmas every single day Hanukkah if
you will yeah sure of course seven crazy
nights that's what the Sandman said hate
crazy
gang bespoke post is absolutely
fantastic they send you cool guy stuff
it's the winter time get some cool guy
outdoor gear get some grooming stuff get
some stuff for your home bar it's all
top shelf stuff and they'll deal with
small businesses look at that yeah huh
it's fantastic baby uh I'm a client as
well they send me stuff every month it's
great it's stuff you don't know you need
until you get you go holy [ __ ] this is
what I wanted now I'm better I'm cooler
than my friends I'm cooler than my
brother I'm cooler my dad take that you
know to get started just take the quiz
at foxboston.com here and so they're
gonna help them pick the right box for
you they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
each box is valued at around 70 bucks
but you only pay a fraction of that
price look at that uh get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
box of awesome.com another code garbage
at checkout that's box of awesome.com
code garbage for 20 off your first box
box of awesome.com called garbage do it
okay let's talk about mint mobile I love
that big bubble boy yeah you know it you
know what well let's talk about it gang
let's talk about getting a three-month
contract they give you one one month two
months what are you an idiot three
months three months you're giving you
they doubled down I would get it now
because they're gonna realize they made
a big mistake and then they're gonna
cancel this this crazy promo they got
going on crazy on top of all that they
do 15 a month geez it's insane 15 bucks
a month you know why I bet more on
Bernie's today than that no holy cow
pack of heaters that's nuts for a pack
of heaters you lose your phone for a
month I know that's fantastic you have a
Lifetime right there sure dang do
yourself a favor get over to Mint mobile
stop paying big prices at big people
yeah whatever
guys uh my family my lady's been using
mint mobile it's fantastic uh she got it
when she came over here just signed up
it's easy peas to do it all online and
send it right to your door bada bang
bada boom you throw it in your phone
you're out the God darn door there you
go uh or if you need a new device for a
limit time you get six months free when
you sign up and buy a select device and
plan really for a limited time uh you
buy any three month mint Mobile plan
like the big man said you get three
months for free by going to
mintmobile.com garbage at
smithmobile.com garbage cut your
wireless bill to 15 beans a month at
mintmobile.com garbage now back today
back to the show
um yeah I [ __ ] hate painting oh it's
like it does it does scratch that itch
of like the OCD and like the bop bop bop
but after a while I'm like this [ __ ]
sucks brutal handle that up and down a
ladder that and handling drywall the
drywall used to just it's like chalk on
nails too [ __ ] drywall boogies too
drywall boogies are oh it's like [ __ ]
Quikrete up there yeah it's real bad
insulation boogers uh I don't mind you
really get a good cough with that
coughing you coughing up had that real
bad uh when I was in college we were
wiring a high school one of my cousins
had a job while I were in high school
and they had to use a certain amount of
non-union people yeah and we got to go
up into the uh drop ceilings or whatever
it was and pull the wire through and all
that insulation was up there I don't get
you yeah I was hacking that up all
summer sure that'll get me I get plain
bugs real bad airplane oh man couple of
stingers I pee a lot on the plane one to
stretch the legs two IP a lot three
clean out the [ __ ] Batcave the older
I get the more I appreciate you know in
a movie when you see a guy walking
something's going on he walks into the
bathroom and he splashes cold water in
his face washes his face the more the
older I get the more I get that so funny
you say that I oh man me too right I'm
right there blow your nose wait you're
freshing up your face you know what oh
you know what I always think about I
think it was in uh the Gladiator after
that first battle not before he's like
the oh I know what you're talking about
when he washed his hand when he gets
that rose hips or whatever in there like
rose petals and he does this on the back
of his neck and man he just washes away
the day that's what that does dude that
clears out all the bad thoughts watch
that murder right off yeah that raping
and pillagons all gone with a little
cool water to the back of the neck dude
little cucumber water oh man I do that
take away the genocide you know what I
mean I do that when I come home uh like
we're in here for a long you know for
like if we're in here cranking out apps
you're just like your head's all cooking
you're up sitting in traffic on the way
home I get home and I that and when Alec
Baldwin in The Departed puts his face in
the the bowl of ice dude I did that
blows it's all right here's the thing I
did that all the time when I was waiting
tables and I'd stay up all night
reading
doing protein bars and I would I would
get I would get to the restaurant and I
would be like literally you feel like
you're dying yeah it's like you can't
even place it it's it's nervousness it's
sleep you're just so tight your body's
run down your emotions are run down
you're on drugs I get it sorry I'm late
I have my nose in a Colombian best
seller
Gabriel Garcia Marquez
I was reading the love and the time of
loving the time of Colorado
um it doesn't work
you can it only has
limited powers I'll put it that way yeah
I mean it's kind of it's not gonna turn
around a nine-day vendor 10 years of
[ __ ] drug addiction and horrible
anxiety ain't gonna be turned around
with one puff a nice and ice water but
it does feel good yeah you know what I'm
[ __ ] with those cold showers more and
more too they're starting to pay the gas
bill they'll never get me
um that's more and more I read about it
with the circulation sure of course yeah
wow um that you know what else I do I
got bad feet my feet hurt a lot
kids got bad dogs huh my dogs are
barking and girls he's a looker oh yeah
I got bad feet we all got bad feet oh
yeah I got bad feet yeah my feet are
being my dad had bad feet my uncle said
bad seat everybody's got it's wearing on
me more
as of as of recent you know the past uh
six months eight months or whatever I
feel like I'm going flat foot or
something
so that I don't know if I ever told you
this I bought I ain't gonna fight the
Jerry's huh you got flat feet I bought
ice socks yeah you put them in the
freezer
you put them in the freezer and then
after a long day you put them on and you
just like sit there it's like ice packs
but socks how do you get them on if
they're frozen
and how do you get them over your
bunions lettuce they're like elastic
imagine like uh you know a spandex type
ice I don't Toby Google ice song
man never do I feel more old than like
an old lady really been rocking my
purple eyes
they're like can you walk around in them
they don't advise it but yeah so you sit
with your feet up and watch your program
yeah you could say that homsy licks them
they look like yeah God damn it they
look like swim shoes yeah send me what
you said yeah exactly they're a little
send me what you're looking at and I'll
let you know if that's uh that's wild
yikes I have those leg things those leg
compressions
things that go all the way up ladies
relax up there huh we're both really
[ __ ] cooking
girls put your head in some ice or
something like that yeah this is very
similar this is probably yeah this is
very similar there's like ice packs on
the box
there's ice packs on the bottom the
manly color is real nice what is that
mint
holy this may surprise you but they are
in stock really
only two left bye now my ice socks holy
[ __ ]
they're probably nice though it probably
feels that feels fantastic man that's
like what you wear when you survey
volcanoes
well listen that's my version of wiping
my neck off okay Kippy just stands on
two frozen steaks
thoughts of math for dinner
Ah that's all right yeah now you got to
do that [ __ ] man you gotta take care of
yourself be running around this goddamn
country it's the same thing going back
to in the beginning with the with the
dry skin the moisturizer all that stuff
the older you get the more you got to
get you get into those little routines I
know that I've neglected we've neglected
for so long that's why you've got bad
feet that's why I got bad tootsies
uh yeah I mean it is what it is also you
know I'm a bigger guy running around
[ __ ] knees go shin splints the whole
nine yards ice socks I'm telling you you
gotta get hot sauce that's where it's
ate something you can cook a panini on
put my ice glasses on oh my eyes oh your
mom we had one my mom had one of those
like the ice mask oh of course yes it's
the same thing but for your Tootsie yeah
of course of course listen if you've
ever used ice socks out there hit me up
I can't be the only one nice
nice that's a good time
that's a good don't judge me all right
let's keep it moving why is this all you
know why what's a [ __ ] on Kippy day
um
Excellence from Paul B he uh is it
garbage or smoke bong rips of straight
tobacco I break apart American Spirits I
get five to six it's per burning no
that's crazy that's disgusting who needs
a Bernie that [ __ ] heavy bike coming
in I just meant the American Spirits
part
ah take a more blight all day nah that's
brutal and I don't like it when uh
when people mix in I don't like spliffs
whatever they're called people mix in
tobacco in in in the good stuff what's
that do it just makes it burn louder
[ __ ] it makes me sick to my stomach and
look like an idiot in front of chicks
that's what it does I turn green
especially when they don't [ __ ] tell
you they get [ __ ] like fully charging
like a tough guy you four monsters and
they're like Yo dude take it easy
there's tobacco in there it's like what
the [ __ ] then you're all pukey I hate
that [ __ ] I don't get it because you
love tobacco yeah not like that
now I like the hot side hot and the cool
side cool you know what I'm saying try
ice sucks
I've seen a friend or two do a Binger
stinger in my day it doesn't make sense
to me oh how is that out of what like
why don't you just smoke the cig is your
dirtbag a lot of times I'll mix Weed in
like a Swift all right I'll give you
that I remember back in the day no I got
the I got the impression that he was he
was rounding up scroungers he was
rounding up dead soldiers taking their
boots he says I break apart American
Spirit a fresh one that's what that's my
interpretation he would I think he would
then say I take the butts and [ __ ]
that I get that'll give you a good
[ __ ] if you're taking the butts all
day long I've been jammed up my friend
Fun Gym if you're breaking open a pure
American Spirit to slap in the face of
Native Americans all over this goddamn
character
smoke the cig like it was intended
um
our American Spirits are a Native
American company
give that a GOOG
I believe so it better be otherwise I'm
suing
uh crazy I think they own five percent
of it or something like five it's
something crazy come on another five
percent of the market if I remember
correctly this could be uh
bad facts I heard at one point I like
that I like bad facts bad facts with
Kippy and ice this is bad facts and Ice
socks Santa Fe Natural Tobacco Company
Incorporated in parent company Reynolds
American yeah yikes so no
I don't think so parent company but the
the you know subsidiary might be rant
whatever there's some sort of connection
you'd hope so uh
uh either way I remember back in the day
I saw a kid we were in the woods smoking
Bernies like you do it was like a 13
year old or whatever but don't you kid
smoke out there no no smoking this is a
you know it's bad for you
but this kid
put one Sig one lit Sig in each finger
hole you know what I mean so he had four
cigs like that and then went like this
man and smoked four at a time wow man
that's when I realized I wasn't a man
how did he do down at uh dirty go Duke
Chapel Hill where'd he go he's no longer
with us Jesus Christ
smoking multiple cigs at a time you
gotta respect the Ingenuity anything
like that to impress your friends oh
back to the 13th I'm gonna shove it on
my [ __ ]
uh no Native American ownership in any
part of the American Experience just
marketing damn wow
I bet you a camel doesn't even own
camels
wet in their beak
um all right let's see here this one's
from Brian
um never have one red is it garbage you
consistently have your car have a car
for sale in your front yard yeah that's
unless you got good foot traffic yeah it
makes sense yeah something from the
cul-de-sac that's bad some of them move
there's a neighborhood near me
uh that's on the the back of the
neighborhood is on a road or somewhat of
a main road a bigger yeah you know what
I mean and there's a line of pine trees
people that's a perfect people stick
them out there so it's not really in the
front yard it's kind of in the backyard
do you think they wet their beaks on
that a little bit I think they probably
have something worked out I don't think
it's unless unless this guy just has
nine million cars to sell there's one
every few months probably give me 200
bucks
250. you put it back you can use my
reels yeah that I don't mind no
everybody wins in that you move some
merchandise [ __ ] hell a landowner
what's his beak and I don't know
somebody gets a new ride I don't know
how it is now but as a kid that was a
little more of a legitimate thing buying
a car off of somebody I think I bought
the car off of them because I remember
us looking for a new car at one point
and
exclusively that's driving around the
neighborhood that's what we were hitting
sure we weren't going to the [ __ ] uh
you know you know zoleski Auto or
anything like that you know zalesky Ford
we were going around
he had the newspaper ah let me talk to
this newspaper was big you can move some
merchandise in a class in the auto sales
classifieds and I remember just sitting
in the pull-up to the house my dad you
guys stay here don't say it she
everybody shut up how much you want for
that hunky [ __ ] in the front yard my dad
would get out meet the guy halfway up
the driveway and we'd be sitting in the
car like [ __ ] like the Clampetts just
I remember just thinking to myself like
damn we stink
and just knowing it yeah I was okay with
it but I was like man we stink we're in
the car [ __ ] looking
you gonna give us your car good times I
told you but when I moved up to New York
that was my big cash grab was going to
be to sell the Montego and I posted up
at my boy Vinnie with the skinny had a
had a real high traffic uh corner lot a
lot of walking Track for his work let's
post let's throw that out in the outside
yard get some eyes on a Tigo let me wet
my beak a little bit man that did not
move really what we asking eighteen five
what are you trying to do I had financed
that too in-house Finance
give me 180 every month
for 36 months yeah that would be bad
send me a Jihad every month cover my
rent
um
yeah no never went I think we're asking
like five grand I think Kelly Blue Book
like top of the line was like five you
know 5500 I was asking five it just says
OBO yeah give me something I'm tanking
up here
that's trash yeah I remember I remember
seeing as is on a Wrangler as a kid and
they go Dad what does as is mean like it
was like written in the back like or
like the back windshield or what you
know like 1500 bucks as is Penny I go
what's a car mean as is it because
that's a car you don't want to buy yeah
all right that makes sense yeah because
you buy all the problems ago something
wrong with it he was pushing it down the
street
there's no wheels on it
um all right let's see here this one's
from Shan Shan McGrath uh how's it
spelled can I ask uh s-e-a nice what's
the trash here I have a couple of both
in my family I have some H some h a dubs
and I have some scns s-e-s-e-a-n is the
traditional Irish spelling I believe
okay yeah Sean s h a w n garbaggio well
dollar to my cousins I got a couple of
Dubs in there there you go is that
trashy there's a couple of actually I
think it's just Kevin there's two Kevin
cousins in my family what are you who
are you named after
I guess my cousin
he's three weeks older than you
uh the sisters hated each other I'm not
named after anybody my older cousin have
to be I'm not they just pulled Kevin out
of the air I guess they liked it my dad
used to pick names I remember when he
was picking my younger brothers names by
how they would say this is real trashy
it just came to me how they would
announce is a baseball announcer
announcement dude I [ __ ] love that
next up Mike Ryan and I was like Ah
that's pretty good yeah yeah now batting
strike number three Ryan Michael Ryan
yeah that's good that's what he would do
so I guess he probably did some sort of
Dirtbag thing like that you know that's
pretty good famous comedian Kevin Ryan
her quarterback her quarterback yeah his
Ryan drops back oh sacked at the five
years broken leg gonna have to put him
down I think he's crying folks
McMullen it's pretty good McMullen
after a water boy now now here we are
here we are at St Andrews we're on the
ninth t mcmullen's text up steps up
what's his last name do you know who
what his name is Toby yeah yeah yes you
would say to get the flow the name would
be Toby McMullen Kobe mcmullen's a good
golfer name that's Toby's not a guy yes
it is
everybody would get behind Toby Thomas
McMullen on the other hand bleep that
I'm sorry got warrants dude
I like how you're the one it is he's
totally Toby you're the one beeping it
Hey Joe we got that
Now Toby McMullen would be a good golfer
I don't Toby's not a strong name
I can see Toby McMullen having a really
big run at like the U.S open or like one
of those big tournaments like Toby like
Clinton I could see that he'd be a caddy
maybe Toby McMullen on the ladies can
the kid have a dream what do you think
what he was step dad take it easy Toby
McMullen is the mascot of a soccer team
that's a real dog yeah exactly like a
real Bulldog would be Toby McMuffin all
right fine I try to give you a shot of
playing golf
you're fumbling all over the place what
do you mean nine interceptions Kevin
Ryan worst quarterback in the NFL but no
that's really cool name that's the way
you think of it but is that trashy yes I
have two Kevin's uh
uh if you played football your name when
your nickname would be the Jumbotron
if you look at his belly button here
comes the stadium folks
give it up for the parking lot gang
um
you're talking about me right oh yeah
fair enough uh
it would depend the or I I we need to
know a little bit more
where Kevin comes from if you guys have
like a great grandfather named there's
no there's no there's no significant
Kevin and these these two families talk
right
yeah I mean who was born first he was
huh it's different last names though
different last names different middle
names and we're about
15 years apart maybe
12 years apart 12 years apart I mean
yeah that's okay
out of the Italians doesn't feel okay is
different because they they all turn a
middle name and that's like their legacy
they got Johnny Frankie yeah you know
John Francis Tony John Peter you have
that kind of stuff yeah yeah
yeah the Italians did you know they're
30 people what do you want from 50
60. these guidos we like it what they
use six names you know they keep it real
tight yeah the Irish too I guess
huh
trying to think if I have that it's all
like Saints it's all it's all Catholic
[ __ ] I have multiple Patricks in my
family but different Generations that's
different though General I mean Bob same
generation Kevin yeah it's a tough look
it doesn't feel classy nah
hmm you know what I mean yeah we're big
on the
uh the
the maiden name the if the female is a
member of our family
and she marries somebody else obviously
and takes their name their firstborn
will probably have her last name does
that make sense as a first name or a
middle name as a first name
like for example if um
Orion which we have a we have a section
of Ryan's in our family yeah but Ryan's
not fair because that's also a first
name okay you see what I mean okay so
you'd have like
Foley Jenkins it would have to be there
there was there's a board I get the
middle name we do that we'll do that as
the middle name
okay like there's like you know yeah if
it works yeah not Jenkins you know what
I mean it's just kind of like two last
names a little bit a little bit you know
what I mean yeah yeah yeah
there's a it's Dirtbag lineage but yeah
it flows it flows yeah if it if that
that's perfect if it flows we're using
it in honor of that side of the family
yeah
we did have a layer of cousins bean dip
player a hoagie dip we did have a layer
of cousins that went real wonky with
that with the real Irish names I like
that yeah like Ronin and I like the
Italian I like when the Italians stick
it real close too I like that [ __ ] kick
rocks with that I love it
wait would you say Declan Ronan Declan
Ronan Quinn Quinny what shout out to
Quinny yeah Quinn's all right Quinn's a
professional soccer player shout out to
Philadelphia Union there you go yeah
that's his first name yeah that's pretty
cool Quinn Sullivan
they're looking good
see that rolls off the tongue that's no
Toby McMullen
third string caddy on the [ __ ] LPGA
Tour and Kevin there's a cabin as well
cabin's pretty good cat column's good
Kali T yeah but he goes My Collie I know
but the name columns God that's a good
Irish name sounds like too much like
Gollum with me that's what every time I
hear Colin that's what they picture
somebody asking for a ring or see what's
in my pockets
shout out to Cali uh all right let's do
one more thing we gotta get out of here
we didn't even get to it this one's from
Sean which started the whole goddamn
there you go a dirtbag name thing have
you ever used a K-Cup to make more than
one cup of coffee
I have and it comes out a little thin on
the second one I didn't think it worked
yeah doesn't it know it has a hole in it
no it just pokes another hole oh really
just runs it back and you it it looks
the same if you're not like sorry I've
had left it in there and then went to
like you know two hours later went back
to get another one didn't realize I
didn't put it in man and it looks all
right it passes the eye test typically
sure it does not pass the flavor test I
think you'll get a little buzz you'll
get a little caffeine out of it I've
done that with regular pots of coffee
I'll re-run the ground I've done it back
like the remix I've done it oh the
French when you're at it when I'm out of
when I'm out of coffee and it's it's the
winter time The French Press The French
Press you can get away with that you
just use half of the water that you used
the first time and you really got to get
it hot and you're really gonna let it
sit there for a minute it's got a half
life you got to start doing math on them
you gotta steep that [ __ ] yeah but we
gotta wrap it up gang what a fun one
gang love you to death uh-huh and we'll
see you next week peace